MEAL RIGHT FROM UNDERNEATH US.
>> SEAN, THERE IS A MOMENT ON
THE VIDEO WHEN YOU SEE A SKULL
OF FISH, I DON'T KNOW IF THOSE
ARE SARDINES OR KRIL OR
WHATEVER --
>> ANCHOVY I THINK.
>> THEY MUST HAVE SENSED THERE
WERE PREDATORS THERE.
>> RIGHT, WELL LIKE YOU SAID, I
HAD MY FACE DOWN IN THE WATER
AND THE ANCHOVY SWAM UNDERNEATH
ME GOING HORIZONTALLY AND ALL OF
A SUDDEN, THEY CHANGED DIRECTION
TRYING TO GET OUT OF THE WATER.
AT THAT MOMENT, I KNEW THAT
THERE WAS A -- SOMETHING GOING
ON AND AS -- I HAD NO IDEA THAT
THERE WAS A HUMP BACK WHALE
BEHIND THEM CHASING THEM AND
SECONDS LATER, I PULLED MY HEAD
UP OUT OF THE WATER BECAUSE I
HEARD YELLING AND MADE A BEELINE
TO THE BACK OF THE BOAT.
>> FRANCIS, WHAT WAS GOING
THROUGH YOUR MIND WHEN YOU
REALIZED WHAT WAS HAPPENING?
>> YOU KNOW, I KIND OF SENSED A
LITTLE BIT OF DANGER BEFORE THAT
HAPPENED.
IF YOU WATCH THE VIDEO, I KIND
OF TURN BACK AND TRY TO GO
TOWARDS THE BOAT, AND I RELAXED
A LITTLE BIT AND I DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THAT THE WHALES WERE BEHIND
ME AT FIRST.
I SAW THEM COME DOWN, BUT I
DIDN'T SEE THEM LIKE REACH OUT
OF THE WATER.
>> SO NEITHER OF YOU ACTUALLY
SAW THE WHALES AS THEY WERE
COMING UP?
>> NO, I SAW THEM COMING DOWN.
I THOUGHT SEAN WAS BEHIND ME.
I KNEW HE WAS BEHIND ME AND I
THOUGHT HE WAS INSIDE THE WHALE,
SO I LOOKED BACK AND SAW HE WAS
SAFE, YOU KNOW, I HAD RELIEF AND
WAS ABLE TO LAUGH ABOUT IT
LATER.
>> WOW, SEAN, WERE YOU CONCERNED
THAT THE TAIL MIGHT HIT YOU
BECAUSE GETTING HIT WITH ONE OF
THOSE THINGS I WOULD IMAGINE
COULD EASILY KILL YOU.
>> THAT WAS THE FIRST THING THAT
WENT THROUGH MY MIND.
AS SOON AS I SEEN ALL THE FISH
BOIL COME UP IN MY FACE AND I
HEARD THE YELL AND LOOKED UP AND
SAW THE WHALES, YOU KNOW, JUST
FEET FROM ME, THE FIRST THING
THAT CAME THROUGH MY MIND IS ALL
THE PICTURES YOU SEE WITH THE
TAIL COMING OUT OF THE WATER.
AND I WAS RIGHT IN THE PATH OF
WHERE THAT MIGHT HAPPEN, SO I
MADE A BEELINE TO THE BOAT AND
TRIED TO GET OUT OF THE WAY, YOU
KNOW, AS FAST AS I COULD, AND,
YOU KNOW FORTUNATELY EVERYTHING
HAPPENED THE WAY IT DID AND
NOBODY GOT HURT.
>> DID THEY EVER ANY SOUND OR
JUST THE SOUND OF THE WATER
TURNING?
>> I DIDN'T HEAR ANY SOUND FROM
THE WHALES.
ALL I HEARD A BUNCH OF YELLING
AND COMMOTION ON THE BOAT AND
LOOKED OVER AND SAW THESE TWO
MOUNTAINS STICKING OUT OF THE
WATER.
>> FRANCIS, DO YOU THINK THE
WHALES KNEW YOU WERE THERE?
>> I THINK SO.
I THINK THEY ARE